자, 오늘은 이제 플래닛 하시면은
초보 템 세팅 하시기 어렵잖아요.
과금을 해도 도대체 돈을 어다 써야
되냐. 그래서 그거 가이드를 좀 해
드리겠습니다. 일단은 여러분들이
기본적으로 알아야 될 지식이
뭐냐면은이 잠재 능력이 있는데 잠재
능력이 35레벨에서 바뀌고
75레벨에서 바뀝니다. 그래 가지고
뭐냐? 일단 30레벨은 살 이유가
전혀 없어요. 특히 플레닛은 가운이
진짜 별로다. 어, 파란색 가운 해서
35레벨부터 여러분들이 뭐 그냥 아예
쪼렙템을 아예 한 개도 안 사도
되는데 굳이 산다면은 35레벨부터
사라는 거야. 30레벨 이하는 싸지
말고. 자, 그리고 또 중요한 거.
주스텝 퍼센트가 좋은 거 다들
아시잖아요. 근데 오히려 쪼랩템은
깡스탯 플러스가 효율이 오히려 좋은
경우가 많다. 쪼랩대는 주스탯이 워낙
낮다 보니까 그냥 깡스탯 플러스가
효율이 잘 나온다는 거지. 자,
그래서 이제별로 좀 설명을 해
드리겠습니다. 일단은 과금 유저가
아니면 안 맞춰도 돼요. 안 맞춰도
됩니다. 그냥 뭐 80레벨도 금방
찍기 때문에 75레벨까지 안 맞춰도
되는데 여러분들이 굳이 돈을 쓰고
싶다면은 35레벨 캐치하이부터
맞추셔도 돼요. 근데 이제 문제가
뭐다? 캐츠하이랑 블루인데 40레벨
제한이 40레벨은 또 블루이거든.
얘네들은 매물이 많지가 않아요.
근데이 홀리 크로스링은 매물이
100페이지를 넘어요. 그렇기 때문에
그냥 홀리 크로스링을 사라. 그리고
여기서 살 때 이제 뭐 사라 하실
거면은 106 이런 거 사지 말고
그냥 104%에 뭐 올스탯 3 이런
거 있잖아. 그러니까 깡스텝 붙은 거
요런 거 이제 저렴하게 구매하신
다음에 뭐 귀장식 민첩 이런 거 이제
100%런 거 저렴하죠. 이런 거
떡해서 쓰시면은 파시면 오히려 돈을
니다. 저는 쪼랩템을 사고서 언제나
돈을 벌었습니다. 참고로 쪼랩템들 잘
사시면은 다 이제 돈이 됩니다. 자,
그리고 이제 망토인데 망토는 일단
여러분들이 돈이 썩어 넘으면 이카루스
망토를 사시면 되는데 이카루스 망토
뒤지게 비쌉니다. 그렇기 때문에
이카루스 방토 전혀 추천하지 않고요.
50레벨 망토인이 모험가의 망토
쓰시면 됩니다. 이것도 근데 뭐 굳이
안 맞춰도 돼요. 네. 맞추신다면
이것도 여전히 똑같이 주스태에 이렇게
올스탯 6 이런 건 진짜 좀 달달해.
이런 매물은 솔직히 제가 지금 사
가지고 다시 400에 올려도
팔립니다. 뭐 이런 거 사셔도 되고
그래가지고 이것도 이제 주문서작을
만약에 하실 거면은 망토 힘 주문서
요런 거 바르셔도 되는데 근데
도적법사는 행눈이랑 지력이 둘 다
뒤지게 비싸 가지고 민첩도 그렇고 뭐
그냥 노작으로 쓰셔도 되고 이건
100%가 다 비쌉니다. 자, 그리고
장갑. 직업 장갑은 매물이 없어요.
검색도 여러분들 하려면 귀찮아요.
궁수 35레벨 장갑이 뭐 그레이스고
뭐 40레벨이 뭐 어 저도 몰라요.
찾아봐야 돼. 구글에 옛매, 궁수,
장갑 이런 거 쳐 가지고 검색해야
된다고. 그래서 상당히 머리가
아픕니다. 그래 가지고 못 쓰냐?
그냥 머시킹의 레더 글러브. 아,
그니까 그 메이플지지 이런 거 하면
되는데 귀찮잖아요. 그거 또 언제
찾아봐. 애초에 매물도 없다고
찾으려면 또 머리 아프고. 그래서 뭐
그냥 머시킹의 레더 글러브 요거
쓰셔도 되고 뭐 아니면은 나는 카르마
가위가 아깝다. 진디의 공로모 뭐 둘
중 뭐 아무거나 사시면 됩니다. 아
그니까 검색하면 다 나오는데 귀찮다.
그런게 근본 템도 아니고 그래서 요런
거 쓰시다가 이제 하면 된다. 뭐
검색하면 안 나오는 거 나오는 거 뭐
다 알지 사람들. 그게 그게
귀찮잖아요. 그 다 이제 머리
아프다고 그런 거 하려면. 자,
그리고 이제 상하이랑 전신인데 잠재가
있는 서버는 뭐 잠재가 아니어도
주문서만 하더라도 상하이가 전신보다
좋습니다. 쪼랩템도 마찬가지예요.
근데 이제 문제가 뭐냐? 상위
주문서가 뒤지게 비쌉니다. 뭐 상위
힘 주문서는 그나마 싼데 하이 민첩
얘가 이게 좀 비싸요. 100%도
비싸고 60%도 비싸. 그 두 개
맞추는 거 자체가 돈이 많이 들잖아.
근데 전신가보 민첩성 주문서 60%가
이게 휴지입니다. 그냥 휴지야 이거.
그냥 저렴하다고. 여러분들이 도적이나
전사면 이렇게 이제 전민학이 잘된
35레벨이 체인 퍼플 후르츠 그니까
어차피 여기는 이제 성별 공용으로 다
쓸 수 있어요. 남자가 여저것 쓸 수
있습니다. 그래서 요런 거 이제
적당히 잠재된 거 사시면은 요걸로
이제 80레벨에서 100레벨까지
저렴하게 쓸 수 있습니다. 근데 뭐
궁수 같은 경우는 어차피 최종 템이
상하이라 35레벨이랑 40레벨 매물이
많거든요. 그래서 궁수는 뭐 적당히
이제 이것도 주스태에 깡패 좀 들어간
거 사시면 좀 괜찮아요. 자, 그리고
투군데 어, 뭐 그냥 자투가
짱입니다. 그냥 자투가 다 이겨.
잠재 애매하게 한 쪼렙보다 그냥
노잠재 자투가 다 이깁니다. 근데
여러분들이 만약 돈을 쓰시겠다면은
642 66 44 요런 거 그냥
12% 좀 사시면은 좀 괜찮습니다.
이거 쓰시면 그냥 평생 쓸 수
있어요. 평생. 그리고 혼주하겠다고
깝치지 마시고 그냥 투민 법사면 투지
바르세요. 60파 바르세요라 깝치지
마세요. 그래서 이제 이후 나중에
이제 직업으로 넘어가셔도 되고 뭐
차트 계속 써도 되고. 자, 그리고
신발인데 신발은 이것도 똑같아요.
여러분들 뭐 40레벨 신발, 35레벨
신발 어 막 그 사이트 들어가 가지고
막 찾은 다음에 일일이 무슨 어
비에르 휴즈 치고 뭐 35제 신발
찾아 치고 50레벨 신발 치고 매물도
없고요. 귀찮아. 그리고 뭐 그 뭐
그렇게 껴 그래서 뭐냐 그냥 대충
고무 신발이나 뭐 가죽구두 요런 거
이제 공용 이런 거 사 가지고 또
신발의 이동속도 점프력이 붙거든요.
그래서 그런 거 이제 이속 대충 붙은
거 써 가지고 쭉 한 100레벨까지
쓰시면 좀 편합니다. 자, 그리고
무기인데 무기가 좀 머리 아파.
무기가 근데 원래는 옛매는
10레벨보다 바꿔야 돼. 10레벨마다
바꿔야 되는데 여기는 잠재가 있기
때문에 레벨 차이에 대한 공격력을
잠재 한 줄로 어느 정도 비빌 수
있어요. 그렇기 때문에 이제 대파는
것도 귀찮으니까 대충 20레벨 단위로
이런 거 이제 사 가지고 적당히 뭐
떡작된 거 뭐 두 줄 정도 떼워진 거
사 가지고 쓰시면은 좀 괜찮습니다.
그리고 이제 궁수나 전사 이렇게 이제
공격 속도 좀 빠른 거는 이거 좀
오래 쓰셔도 돼요. 에바는 잠재가 좀
낮아서 오래 쓰기 애매한데 그래도 작
잘됐으면 오케이. 어 매도 그니까
해나 하이랜더는 진짜 거의 뭐
80까지 쓰셔도 됩니다. 저도 해러
80까지 썼습니다. 어 귀찮아. 진짜
무기 바꾸는게 귀찮아. 근데 뭐 이제
바꾸실 거 뭐 50에 바꾸고 뭐
70에 바꾸고 뭐 그러셔도 되는데
그냥 여러분들 이제 선택입니다
이거는. 그러다가 이제 80레벨에
그냥 대충 두 줄 된 거 좀 바꾸시면
되겠죠? 그리고 이제 100렙까지
쓰면 되겠죠? 자, 그래서 최종적으로
이러고 이제 여러분들이 이제 조렙템
세팅을 하고 이제 80레벨 100레벨
찍으면 이제 어떻게 하냐? 일단은
공용부인데 요거는 17 18% 최소로
맞추세요. 21%도 오케이. 공용
부위는 정말 저렴해요. 큐브 확률이
네배잖아. 그래서 여기서는 좀 힘을
줘도 돼. 최소 18%는 맞추면
좋아요. 그냥 진짜 이거는 후회 없이
쓸 수 있습니다. 요거는 그냥 좀
힘을 줘 가지고 공용 부위는 줘도
된다. 여러분들이 돈이 좀 많으면은
뭐 텔걸도 좀 사셔도 됩니다. 뭐
R이면 R온목이면 더 좋은데 뭐 R은
나중에 맞추셔도 되고 인두가 진짜
쓰레기라서 120대 그냥 바로 텔걸
바로 껴 주면은 이거 상당히
괜찮아요. 아직은 좀 가격이 있긴
한데 그리고 이제 방어구 같은 경우는
여러분이 이제 15%에서 18% 그냥
이거는 여러분들이 그냥 예산에 따라서
하시면 돼요. 이런 망작 같은 거
15퍼 요런 거 사셔도 상당히
괜찮습니다. 뭐 요런 거 사셔도
가성비 괜찮게 나옵니다. 그 무기
같은 경우는 이제 선택을 하시면
돼요. 만약에 내가 진짜 초
저자본이면은 이런 거 이제 적당히
작된 거에 이제 공격력 두 줄, 에픽
두 줄 이런 거 이런게 이제 얼마 안
하거든요. 다른 직업들도 에픽 두 줄
이런 거 싸거든. 뭐 적당히 60%
뭐 4, 5작, 6작 이렇게 된 거.
그런 거 사 가지고 그냥 쭉 쓰셔도
되고 내가 이제 돈을 좀 더
쓰시겠다면은 00이 제일 좋긴 해.
00이 제일 좋은데 뭐 ộng공도
나쁘지 않고요. 뭐 공의 공공 이런
것도 좋습니다. 물론 데미지 6%나
공격력 6%면은 깡공에 비해 좀
약하긴 한데 근데 뭐 그렇게 완벽한
거 맞추려고 하면은 돈이 비싸잖아.
그러니까 그 약간 하자 있는 공퍼
댐퍼를 이용해서 2.5줄을 쓰자.
요거야. 그니까 2.5줄 느낌으로
가자고. 2.5줄. 그러고서 이제
만약 여러분들이 보스 무기를 맞춘다면
이제 보공이 정말 효율이 좋기 때문에
보공 무기 사시면 되고 아니면 뭐
리버스로 넘어가는 것도 괜찮죠.
그리고 정말 좀 여러분들이 아 나는이
사냥무이랑 뭐 이런 거 같이 맞추기
싫다 하시는 분들은 뭐 보공의 공공
보공 보공 30에 공공 요런 거 이제
좀 가격 괜찮으면은 요런 거 사셔
가지고 이도류로 쓰시는 것도
저자분들에게는 나쁘지 않기는 합니다.
어 근데 좀 투자를 하실 거라면
나중에 후회할 수 있다. 어 결국에는
이제 보공이 더 답해. 그래서 요런
식으로 좀 세팅을 하시면 좋을 것
같아요.